i've done the seven-day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations prophecy system you can
build a habit with the quran by seven
day free trial bonuses no credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dear friends what you're about to see
from what i've heard from the internet
is a brave young ukrainian ukrainian
girl if you want to however you would
like to pronounce it
fighting off the oppressors with her
bare
hands
let's watch this carefully and let's
analyze it for ourselves
[Music]
now as you guys can see
we can say that she is admirable
brave damn brave has got the courage and
is determined to kick those oppressors
out
one little catch
she's not ukrainian
she is palestinian and that soldier is
not russian
he is
israeli occupier zionist
now this does not take away from the
fact of what russia's doing to ukrainia
not at all we are against any kind of
civilian casualty or oppression or
attack against any nation
every nation believes they have a right
to that's not my point here the point is
this that people actually thought this
was a ukrainian girl
um standing up to a soldier which is
russian and he went viral and rightly so
but the moment you add in she is
palestinian and he is israeli let me
tell you something the story changes
maybe he was watching this like this
and now maybe you're watching it like
this
and that is exactly our point
why the double standards why the
hypocrisy of the media and only that
this is just one part i'm going to be
giving you guys in the next couple of
days snippets of the double standards
and hypocrisy in little sound bites so
you can see how disgusting and how vile
these double standards are human beings
are human beings like allah says in the
quran if you kill one human being not
one muslim one human being it's as if
you've killed the whole of humanity
that is islam's stance on these matters
till next time watch out for more videos
where we tackle these issues with little
snippets and show you guys the stand
double standards and hypocrisy share
this far and wide and let the whole
world see what is really going on i may
allah protect innocent children
civilians and kids